Thomas: Hello! I'm Thomas. and
I'm gonna be
Thomas: your guide for today's task. But
the task is called record a goose siding 3,
Thomas: and the slug is UOCI dash RGS. Dash 5
Thomas: and today I'm actually on zoom text.
Thomas: I have a set to 1.4
Thomas: and have the color set to dark mode, and that makes it much easier for me
Thomas: to understand the screen, because light modes cause headaches for me. I also suffer from seizures.
And so I saw for dark modes.
Thomas: and also my cursor is much bigger than normal. Zoom text makes it about twice the size and yellow in color.
Thomas: And so right now I can't see the edge of the paper or the edge of the screen.
Thomas:  and over here I can see.
Thomas: Okay, that's over here. So like, if I'm all the way to the left, I can't say I can't see I can see information about, but it cuts off right there
Thomas: and then whenever I put to the right side screen. I can't see record. I can see ORD, a goose siding.
Thomas: But yeah, it's basically the screens itself.
Thomas: But I'm using a magnifying glass to see the screen. That's the way I look at it.
Thomas:  but yeah, let's hop into it. And so first, I'm gonna just try some of these links.
Thomas:  and so
Thomas: this section of the screen's not dark mode. I'm not sure why that is the bottom half in dark mode. but for some reason this section's not white mode. Still
Thomas: and normally dark mode makes everything dark.
Thomas:  in this section as well. The top half of the screen is white.
Thomas: and the warm half's plaque.
Thomas: But I'm half the black one half. It looks pretty good, because I can see these are in blue. The
Thomas: boats and waterways and the coasts.  I'm sorry about the pause I just need. I needed
Thomas: test clarifications. And so I'm just gonna click one more or so. Remember these. I'm just make sure they're visible.
Thomas:  and they're visible.
Thomas: But I'm gonna go ahead and start now.
Thomas: Tell us if you like, geese. And so
Thomas: yeah, everything's black. And that's what black, dark mode's supposed to do.
Thomas:  I'm just looking around because,
Thomas: okay, so
Thomas: let's say red.
Thomas: And they're. you know.
Thomas: goose.
Thomas: Okay, that's good.
Thomas: Okay, so let's go with
Thomas: today's date, 0 3 0 6 0 3
Thomas: zeros. Okay,
Thomas: this is the first problem. I see. Instead of
Thomas: you have to tab over or click over. And so normally, after you, input the date or the 16 4, you can 16
Thomas: 0 4. But it doesn't select it like that. It's basically an endless pit, that.
Thomas: yeah. And so this needs to be the individual date today just 2 days, and then switches to the month and 2 days for the month or 2 date for the month and 4 days for the year. And so they need to manually or automatically switch over. Once you start typing and you get to 2 numbers. That's the end of that section and the month and the year 4 numbers.
Thomas: yeah, that make it much easier and much more fluid. For me. I'm gonna use the tab key to switch over. But
Thomas: that's just because.  my 24.
Thomas: Okay.
Thomas: Okay. Now, let's say, I want to change the red feather goose to a brown feather goose.
Thomas: Okay,
Thomas: this thing is erasing. Everything are typed.
Thomas: And I just want to type brown in the section. But since it doesn't have the red any more.
Thomas: I have to now type in Feather Goose.
Thomas: which is more work for me.
Thomas: and
Thomas: there's messy
Thomas: goose
Thomas:  And so I think that if you could
Thomas: maybe make it to where all these things are filled in with what I had done originally. It'd be better experience.
Thomas: Hmm.
Thomas:  but
Thomas: 2,017. But since it's not
Thomas: it kind of next headache for me.
Thomas:  But yeah, let me switch this to red for the goose.
Thomas: Oh, yeah. So yeah, this needs to be fixed
Thomas: alright. Well, it should be my eyes.
Thomas: and that there.
Thomas: hmm
Thomas: and I don't like that. You have to
Thomas: enter the date also cause I was just trying to change the goose. And I have to input the date again.
Thomas: And so
Thomas: they need to. Well, you guys should have them. Help me by remembering these things.
Thomas: Because I don't have to end restart all them. Or maybe we just have a button. You can click to redo everything. Because basically, you're doing that. You're redoing everything.
Thomas: Which is what you want to do. Or if it is, help me, just let me know I'm gonna use it all.
Thomas:  but actually let me try the change. What happens with my devil? Nothing. Okay. Well, since it's
Thomas: I just kind of
Thomas: a try website.
Thomas:  all the geese. Okay? So I think that I'm done.
Thomas: Yeah, I'm done. And so
Thomas: I can't exactly think of everything I said. But
Thomas: the biggest thing was that
Thomas: is that saying changing just the feather goose color. I have to do the whole thing all over again.
Thomas: and I think that'd be pretty easy to remember what I input the first time.
Thomas: But it doesn't remember that.
Thomas: And so I have to read it all as soon as I
Thomas: click, I want to change the color.
Thomas: I have to also change the date and the
Thomas: all the answer. After that, actually, I'm curious. I wanna change the okay. No, I don't like yeast.
Thomas: Yeah, alright. And so basically.
Thomas: they're resetting, based on the item you choose to click on. And so I didn't want to reset everything. I just wanted to set the yes or no
Thomas: and I know you guys shouldn't do that
Thomas: But yeah. And so I did like the site.
Thomas: I do like East.
Thomas: but there are little things like the
Thomas:  Brilliant answers don't stick to the questions that. Yeah, it kind of seems like
Thomas: is lackadaisical. Him on mindset.
Thomas:  But yeah, that's just my thoughts on the whole experience.
Thomas: I hope you enjoyed this short but sweet experience. I appreciate you listening to me, and have a good day.